this is a production of cornell
university
yeah uh welcome everybody to the the
sixth week of the cornell turf show this
season uh this is episode 11. our guest
today dr mike fedonza of penn state
we're going to talk about
i'm sure a lot of things but fairy ring
and these
uh root drenches uh that that i know
we're getting close to i but uh
as always frank you're gonna start
reviewing the weather here and and
that's a real roller coaster we're in
for another uh unfortunately another
week of roller coaster weather which is
going to
throw a wrench in the system there but
as always frank you've got uh some
interesting images to start us off off
for the day
good morning and thank you carl
carl and i just returned from a
triumphant golf shoe
experiment in north scottsdale arizona
at whisper rock we had the pleasure of
walking six miles in a circle for five
hours
testing golf shoes for footjoy so mike
knows
firsthand the crazy stuff we do to
generate data but i thought we'd start
with a funny picture uh golf course
superintendent posted i think somewhere
outside a restaurant or something that
spring is simply not installing
but you can't have a good turf show it's
never a good turf show without a good
dog picture right there's something
about golf course superintendents and
their dogs and every once in a while a
dog gets in position and you just cannot
resist it
a reminder carl before we get to you and
your bmp minute for today that in a
couple of weeks um we won't be here in
the studio
we will be out in the field uh with the
gcsa ny at the links of greystone uh tim
han will host us for a walk and talk and
hopefully we don't get that crap weather
like those penn state knuckleheads got
the other day scouting for
scouting for annual bluegrass weevil in
the snow i i never thought i saw
something as funny as that all right
carl tell us what the bmp is for today
yeah frank so we're going to talk about
uh i'm sure some some fungicide
applications today and anytime we talk
about pesticide applications we like to
draw people's attention to this uh erp
poster with our friends at the p2i
center spot treatment right and
identifying areas to spot treat and and
going further on that
just treating only the areas that you
want to treat
so we can see here we've tested gps
sprayer data and how that can reduce
your pesticide use um and we've done
this at skinny atlas country club we're
hoping to do this a couple more courses
with ken ross's uh frost ink
sprayer and we saw about 15 reduction in
pesticide use
using that gps sprayer just spraying the
areas
that you want to right just the fairway
and not having that overlap this image i
created that really i think highlights
not only the the overlap that you
normally see with manually spraying but
those triangles right we're not spraying
squares we're trying to fit a square peg
into a round hole here uh spraying a lot
of these surfaces you can save about 15
on fairway areas right and that's 20
acres 25 acres worth of product that's a
lot and you can actually save more on
greens because greens tend to be rounded
you get a lot more of that these these
triangles right that you can see off in
the turf
your return on an investment uh can be
very quick if you if you spray a lot
it's going to be quicker you're going to
save more product save more money so
it's a really good investment from that
perspective at skinny atlas we saw less
than two years roi
save time and improve turf quality right
you're not gonna have those overlap
those lines if you're spraying
fertilizer you're not gonna see that
seed heads i know people like um not
having that that ring around the greens
getting into colors growth regulators
bill croiser has talked a long time
about keeping growth regulators off your
collars if you get color decline
a lot of great things can happen with
gps sprayers i think of those as spot
treatment
tools and you can save a lot of money
and reduce your pesticide use pesticide
risk uh through employing them we we've
been a we've been really reluctant as an
industry to embrace this and what we
found up in skinny atlas carl was that
the the original spraying was done very
slowly at high volume
and if you've got you know fairways that
take you all day to spray for example
you're going to get a really rapid
return on investment just in saving time
and things like that and i think for
especially what we're going to talk
about with mike today mr
fairy ring mushroom himself you know
we're going to get to the genetics of
the mushroom family that mike emanates
from but let's start with a couple of
things first
seeding going on in a lot of areas that
got damaged superintendents posting
pictures about germination uh here in
these slits
if you get really close into these
pictures you can start to see the slits
for those of you on the podcast i'm
looking at a slit with a really small
bent grass seed coming up one of the
other things that's critical to get
going is the water right you don't think
about this because e.t is not very high
and you know maybe it's been raining a
lot which of course we're going to show
in a second it's been raining a lot
but having that water ready to get out
there and encourage establishment you
get a dry day with wind
right we're going to be 75 80 degrees
this weekend uh even up here in upstate
new york
and having water available to keep these
greens going is going to be uh critical
and even if you can't get the whole
system charged obviously being able to
hand water is is better than nothing
particularly in the damaged areas uh jed
newsom at the springfield country club
continues to post great pictures about
uh you know what they're doing to get
these greens recovered out there he
talked about putting uh these little
greenhouse effects a little barrier in
there create a little humidity to
talking about how rapidly the
temperature goes up
under these kinds of uh remediation
conditions and so carl just that great
picture you you see it on slack to me
this morning one we use a lot when we
submit research reports to give people a
view of what the year was like of how
much out or
within temperature periods we are and
boy if this isn't a roller coaster you
know i don't know exactly you know what
what can be it's a classic example and
you know you're looking at you know well
above normal and almost touching record
max and then well below normal you know
from you can go from almost a record
high
to a record low within five days right
so you know this is the signaling of a
changing climate that we're going to
have to get used to and i don't know how
to really adapt to it and think about
what are the strategies we need to
employ it was a cooler
than normal week as you got closer to
the water and up into maine it was a
little bit above normal but overall
everybody was talking about it being on
pause again last week and we're
expecting a continued pause
for the coming week following a warm-up
uh we'll be back down in the 30s and 40s
by wednesday next week so we're going to
warm up and we're going back down again
now the forecast as you can see is
starting to really pick up we're
starting to push degree days because no
matter what that yellow star in the sky
keeps climbing and as it does
everything's keep everything gets warmer
and warmer now a lot of times what we
start to talk about at this time of year
with growing degree days or annual
bluegrass weevil we had old on
professor kostromitska on a couple of
weeks ago and she continues to say look
at the bottom here resist the temptation
to use an adulticide before the half
green half gold timing in new england
she's predicting last week of april
first week of may so we still you know
to get our these insecticides to be most
effective on this provi
really damaging pests getting that peak
adult emergence is always our goal and
even the guys just a couple of days ago
in virginia you know they got angle
bluegrass weevil chewing on bank grass
down in virginia they're saying we're
not ready yet it's not peak yet yeah you
see them you can scout i'm sure ben even
found them in the snow the other day but
you want to see that you're getting to
peak levels here now from the rainfall
perspective obviously when you look at
total precip everybody got a little bit
the closer you got to the great lakes a
little bit more but you were still
getting three in some places four inches
of moisture and looking at precip minus
p-e-t again
widespread wet areas throughout the
northeastern united states most people
are pretty wet you got to go all the way
down to virginia to find some uh
deficits now and
hard to say maybe a little bit drier
maybe near normal we didn't get a firm
uh feeling on this but i think as you go
up and you get warm you're probably
likely to get some more water and when
you go down and get cool you're likely
to probably get a little bit less now
as we get to our guest today the
transition is soil temperature right and
if you paid attention last week we were
almost in the 60s low 60s last week
certainly in the upper 50s and now
you're hard-pressed to find creeping
into the low 50s again so we've
obviously slowed down right and so when
we look at our guidance on some of these
things using soil temperature to get
some of these soil borne pathogens right
there's two
triggers here that we pay attention to
for fairy one for fairy ring a little
bit cooler one for summer patch a little
bit warmer right you've got a collection
of fungicides for summer patch a smaller
but still big collection of fungicides
uh for fairy ring but here's my paisan
i'm so happy to have you and every time
i see a picture of your mother it
reminds me of my late mom they looked a
lot like our moms would have loved each
other um twitter handle right your
twitter handle with with dino and frank
sinatra when i get to travel to palm
springs i go to some of these places
that these guys used to hang out and
then apparently you were with the
mushroom family for easter and they had
antipasto mushrooms hanging around what
a great day you shouldn't tweet this
stuff if you don't want it to be shown i
just
that's the
mushroom collection here
so mike descends from a mushroom family
and we'll talk about that in a second so
here we are talking fairy rings let me
set you up mike
first off this is a very strange name
for a
sort of a soil-borne issue i'm not even
sure i want to call it a pathogen
because it doesn't really necessarily uh
it doesn't attack the plant so you've
got all these funny terms and things
where fairy rings come from
you've got something that's happening in
the middle and growing out radially
right now some of these things i've read
can be a thousand years old can be miles
and miles long right so we have this
particular collection of them in turf
that we've classified as type one two
and three and i'm so glad to be doing
this in front of the world expert so you
correct me at the very end how i'm doing
so you got one that leads to
hydrophobicity that's the one that makes
me nervous you got one that makes me a
little green i don't know if that makes
me nervous and you got one with
mushrooms i don't really know what to
think about that one yet so so again you
look at the variety of symptom types
here's the type one various types of
hydrophobicity probably the one that
wedding agents and fungicides play into
here's type 2 the greening one and then
of course the one with the presidio my
seats and again in the bottom right you
see really interesting pictures uh
in the forest about this now i will ask
you mike uh right before we bring you on
here we saw something really fascinating
at um
saratoga national golf club
when we were walk doing our walk and
talk
uh joe lucas showed us
uh places where the geese were
preferentially feeding the birds and
were preferentially feeding
on the fairy rings themselves
uh you can see some of the let me let me
see you can see the debris well this is
this is this is goose poop here but here
you can see the plants chewed off and
this is the remnants of the fairy ring
have you ever seen this before
no i have not you might have stumbled on
some kind of um biological control maybe
they like the much the taste of
mushrooms
i've not seen that yeah i don't think
he's definitely got type one out there
now listen before i bring you in what a
great publication i spent you know
prepping for this while i was in the
airplane yesterday flying back i was
reading and catching up on this this was
a really interesting paper that most
people would say is you know very geeky
what do you need an index for but what i
really like is you know you set up how
to evaluate it and study it and it looks
like when i read some other things that
you write you really like this early
curative three-step plan
airfly
right to get the water in right uh
water
wetting agent and fungicide
water you know wetting agent and
fungicide you feel really strongly about
this so listen let me bring in stop
looking at slides
i care
what type i've got
do i care what kind of fun a fairy ring
i've got because you got a lot of
organisms causing this malady do i have
to worry about what i've got to
determine how i'm going to control it or
do the strata or manage it so to speak
do the strategies all work across the
board am i right on the type 1 versus
type 2 and type 3. right i think you're
correct on that because they're over
documented over 60 basidiomyc species
that cause these visual farriering
symptoms in turf
wow i think we can get hung up on is it
like a perdon
this is it morasmius
i think right now we have to look at um
the the visual symptoms type one type
two type three
um you mentioned you know when you see
the mushrooms popping up and that's kind
of cool to see you look at the mushrooms
and we can identify the organism the
exact species by the by the mushroom by
the fruiting body a lot of times the
mushrooms to me indicate
that that fungus is present keep an eye
on those sites because uh later on in
the year those sites can dry out very
very they could be like an indicator
site it could dry out first under will
stress or drought stress um that paper
you mentioned by the way is uh with my
colleague dr henry webster and dr derek
settle we the three of us came up with a
way to
to provide an index number for fairing
to make it not easier but um more
manageable when we're conducting fairing
research trials because as you said the
fungus the basidiomycin colonizes the
fats and organic matter in the root zone
it's not infecting the turf directly
like pythium or rhizoctonia would so to
get back to your point um
the uh
the control of the fair ring is i think
it's in my opinion it's all the same no
matter what the syria and species you're
dealing with i i like the agronomic
approach to this isn't in other words
get air in the root zone um
mitigate or minimize those wet dry
cycles in the zone
um i like the wetting agent to help with
turf recovery and and to combat the
hydrophobic conditions that often occur
and and then as the basidiomycin breaks
down that organic matter oftentimes
you'll get a release of the ammonium
that builds up which is causing these
dead necrotic zones
so almost like the superintendent guys
got to wear their agronomic hat to
recover this you're not going to squirt
some magical fungicide and everything's
going to recover
um and then the fungicide piece
uh you got to have that in my opinion
with the wetting agent to get it
uniformly distributed and dispersed to
the targeted area and so this is a
classic example of carl's bmp of spot
treatment in other words if you had
fairy
uh maybe on a couple of putting greens
you wouldn't douse all 18 greens you'd
go to those areas airfie
wedding agent fungicide drench right and
and
first off you'd spot treat rather than
try to treat everything right
yeah in my opinion i would spot treat
unless
unless you know if guys have chronic if
superintendents have chronic problem on
every green or
you know repeated problems over the
years of several greens
then maybe treat those several greens
but uh
starting to see it like i was on a golf
course last last week in central pa
and there was three greens that started
to have some early symptoms of fairy
ring and my advice was just like you
said just spot treat those areas see
what happens it may be a one and done
thing
might be just some anomaly but if you
see these fairings showing up on all 18
greens over the year following this year
next year then then think about a whole
total program approach but right now i
like the spot treat and don't forget the
aeration punching holes watering don't
forget to come back the next day or day
or two later and water again don't be
afraid to do that um i don't think we
can ever water in these materials too
much
in fact that's what you say is probably
one of the reasons they fail oftentimes
right mike is that we don't get enough
water
when we apply can you talk about that
for a little bit i mean i have a picture
of the guy hand with hand watering with
a tablet to me that must be the gold
standard to be really able to drench it
in just the overheads you got to run
those things a lot longer than you want
to probably to get that material down
into the root zone right uh yeah frank
that's a good point i like the tablets
and just the spot treating because you
get a lot of water you get all that sort
of that water movement that volume of
water that moves through there breaks
all that surface tension what's special
and
when you're using overhead irrigate you
know irrigation sometimes god says well
i ran it three times that's enough you
need you know a quarter in it sometimes
they try to pin me on how much water do
you need well you need as much as you
need pools or
find out try to see where the fairing is
is residing in the thatch upper root
zone
water to get through there could be a
quarter inch could be three um
you know three tenths of an inch um some
guys maybe they don't want to water that
much maybe water a tenth of an inch or
in the morning and then come back later
another tenth another i mean
elaine treadway has been looking at this
right lane and his group down in nc
state not necessarily for fairy ring but
just trying to get material moved down
they've they've they've put like a you
know like an inch of water or three
quarters of an inch of water and it
barely moves an inch
through the flashlight
right that's correct uh frank that
they've done jim kearns group follow it
up with oh that's right jim curran sorry
i forgot
and uh yeah they they did posted
application post irrigation
of the fun decides to really try to get
that fungicide to move
the good news is the fungicides aren't
going to move much right they're not
going to get contaminated they're
they're tied up they're doing their job
but you need to really put a lot of
water behind it to get it past that
thatch into that root zone to get those
to get the fungicides especially with
summer patch and take all patch get it
down there where the root hairs are and
the same thing with fairing um so don't
be afraid to
it's a it's a delicate dance right you
gotta they don't saturate the roots and
that's why i like punching holes needle
toning or coring to open up get some air
moving down there get the water down
there get that fungicide down there but
more importantly get the wetting agent
down there to do okay so i wanna
understand this thing a little bit
better now we got the control thing
everybody that was really interested in
paying attention is
they're all satisfied are we seeing more
fairy rain why does it pop up and then
go away sometimes
um is it our as we started to dry our
golf courses out mike right
firm and fast right yeah are fairy rings
really a consequence of our persistent
uh for you know uh wanting fast and firm
and also
lower end
and sandy soils um
what can you say about why we're seeing
maybe more fairy rings are we seeing
more fairy rings than we used to maybe
we're not using metal fungicides anymore
and so we're seeing it because of that
what are your thoughts on why these
things pop up sometimes
yeah i write i wrote an article a few
years ago for the greek greens keepers
over there in in europe and in the uk
because they were seeing more and more
fairing so we studied this a little bit
further basically like you said just
drawing down the root zone
again aim toward firm and fast
conditions but also more maybe perhaps
more conscious of water management
and and we're drying we're drying the
root zone down too much when you get
that lack of soil moisture
when there's adequate soil moisture the
fairing fungus the basilio my seed grows
thoroughly it does its job the mycelial
you know
vegetative part of that fungus
everybody's happy
down and once it go into reproductive
life cycle it starts scavenging water
and nutrients
that's when you get the hydrophobic
hydrophobicity part coming in the type
one rings so we can we can dry the soil
down too much we can go past that
critical water content now you mentioned
earlier in the slides i appreciate
showing those family slides um
i grew up on a mushroom farm my father
was a mushroom farmer and on easter
sunday we visited my one cousin and and
she has a mushroom
business and that's why she has all the
mushroom figures in her kitchen but we
used to do that in the mushroom farm we
used to we used to wet the compost beds
and then dry them down wet them and dry
them down and the more you dry them down
then the mush the mycelium would go into
production and produce the fruiting
bodies so i think in a way that's what's
happening uh our golf courses
less nitrogen so we're not masking the
fairing symptoms but i think it's really
comes down to the root zone the soil
moisture in the root zone
that's where i think wetting agents
helps at least mitigate those wet dry
extremes and we can provide some
uniformity some uniform or consistency
of moisture in the root zone and now
mitigate the um
so this is brilliant so what you're
saying is
as we know right presidio my seats are
sacrifice right they're chomping on dead
stuff primarily they like organic matter
and lignin yep yep right all right so
they're breaking down which we like
right because it keeps our lignans and
that's under control but you're saying
when they feel stress of some kind like
a drought uh dry period they move into a
reproductive phase and to when they do
that they start to scavenge the water
and the nitrogen and that's what
visualizes itself are there some root
zones or soils more prone to having
that will behave this way
or are they everywhere and sometimes
randomly it happens we just don't know
yeah no that's a great that's a great
insight frank it's um i think they're
more prone on sandy soils uh they happen
on mineral soils clay and and silt loams
and
definitely on mineral soils but on sandy
soils they're just more more prevalent
on sandy soils um we see this in in
scotland england and in the netherlands
in northern europe um in the united
states our sane based root zones are
more prone to uh perhaps more prone to
drying out and more prone to these
faring
invasions or uh fairing loves to occupy
those
those
sand based soils there's a lot of air
space in there for the mycelium to move
through
and um
you're right when things dry down uh
don't forget those sand sand based root
zones
um the the mycelium the fungal mycelium
could
you know um
exude various you know sort of um
compounds that that also contribute to
hydrophobicity local spotting and water
repellency issues
so it's it's a challenge there was a
paper that came out a couple years ago
from uh from an italian sciences
university pisa believe it or not
during fungi um ecosystem engineers and
it makes sense as the mycelium is moving
through the root zone and that's it's
trying to manipulate its environment to
grow and get get a ecological foothold
and any and you mentioned the um
some of these fairing fungi can grow
from miles there's there's the humongous
fungus in northern michigan and there's
one in in the um
out in washington state in oregon
and that occupied you know the farced
areas that that cover you know
several miles worth of mycelial network
it's pretty fascinating
so so
can i manage them with just wedding
agents if what you're telling me is that
this is really about moisture
and you know i'm of course probably
worried more about this on on greens
with sandy stuff although i will say
joe's got at carr right saratoga
national he's got he's in a swamp
he's got swampy soils
uh
and so over the years now i think maybe
he's put sand on him a couple of times
but in general he's got uh pretty swampy
soils that he's been having these really
big hydrophobic rings that are starting
to happen can i manage it with just
wedding agents can will the fungi just
play nice or will it always lead if
hydrophobicity seems to be the big issue
that really causes me trouble can i just
do it with wetting agents i i think
wetting agents can help mitigate the
visual symptoms and not just wetting
agents too
think about a whole organic matte
organic matter management piece there's
a golf course near me
uh with a severe organic matter layer in
in the kentucky bluegrass roughs which
they can't really do much about
economically whatever and that's where
we all we often see a lot of fairing
showing up in the middle of the summer
because it has such a fact
thick thatching and organic matter layer
but i think you can use wetting agents
and cultural practices to to mitigate
the symptoms to minimize symptoms may
perhaps you'll still get some fairing
but it won't be as severe
um so
if you're looking to commit you know
use your fungicide budget so to speak
diseases i think you might be able to do
that
for the knockout blood the fungicide
wedding agent combination but then
maintain a wedding agent program or a
soil moisture management program to uh
to keep those fairing symptoms in check
or at least it won't be as severe
what i you know one of the things
speaking of the environmental side of
this and then carl i'm happy to take
some comments and questions but but i
will say the transition
to you carl is that a lot of guys down
south spray a lot of fungicides for this
particular problem when you get it in
southern right on in warm season turf
mike i gotta tell you it's i've seen it
on green they've basically become
unplayable and i think you've got so
much that gets a feeling yeah it gets a
foothold and is there something about
warm season grass that's worse than cool
season grass that it gets worse down
there is it organic matter and sandy
soils and drying out
i believe so i think i know my buddy uh
you remember dr john cesar there in
southern florida
he battles fairing
from january to may and they're sort of
dry season and it persists
um so you need that that wetting agent
to kind of keep the moisture going but
also the fungicides got to keep keep the
presidio my seat at bay um
i think it's just i think it's the
environmental conditions saying could be
the bermuda grass and the organic matter
that's
you know contributing it could be a
certain species down there that's just
more aggressive they get more of the
lycoperdon bavista puffball types
something to do
with it but but i don't think um years
ago
you know when many of the fungicide
companies they all have great products
for fairing came out with these fairing
programs there was some there was some
non-negative feedback but i got some
comments wow i made this application
with the right soil temperature and
fairing still came back well you're not
going to make one fungicide application
to get season long further in control
um it's a great start and it's great to
knock it back and keep it in check but
um different species can appear
throughout the summer you know so so
it's not one application and you're good
for the whole season you gotta stick to
the program if you're gonna if guys are
gonna try that what do you think
yeah the the one thing and mike you said
it was important to figure out how far
down that is and
and we talk about using soil moisture
meters and i see a lot of people use
kind of the one and a half or the three
inch probes
um finding out how far down it is does
that require an actual soil probe a
physical soil probe and you go in and
kind of feel
the wetting profile how far down and
yeah
is that taking a small probe or soil
profiler and and see a lot of times you
you could you might actually actually
visually see some mycelium in the fats
or you could do the smell test if it
smells like mushrooms or sometimes
you'll see the
thatcher the upper root zone sort of
breaking down and you may see this
orangey brown coloration these organic
acids being being sort of leaked out
from the fungus so see
with some some observation you could
definitely tell where that where that
fungus is is residing
and that'll help you know
i'll guide you as far as how much water
to apply okay
what about the old what about the old uh
italian guy move like dan danelli said
his dad used to go to the good greens
that didn't have fairy ring take some of
the soil from there and mix it into bad
greens that had fairy ring to see like
uh you know like um
you know like the fecal inoculation when
you've got uh
you know
bowel syndrome right what do you think
about that old uh method of mixing the
soils is there something to be said for
that competition or is like you and i
know damn dan you and me are completely
nuts yeah
i know you get three italians in the
room
that's what i mean
there is something about those old kind
of wives tales or old italian tales i i
think what really helps is just mixing
the soil
is mixing and so disrupting that
mycelium
and and probably mixing the soil
introduces some
some aeration and there's physical
properties chemical probably biological
properties
there's a lot happening in the horizon
sphere that we're just starting to learn
about
um
and so uh i think you're getting more
benefit from physical mixing than
anything else
okay go ahead carl get us out of here
thanks for joining us mike
yeah thanks a bunch mike uh a nice half
an hour well spent there yeah my dog
rocky kept
and the mushroom pictures as well you
miss mushrooms and rocky so
thanks everyone for joining episode 11.
uh we'll be back tomorrow we'll have
raka swan talk about uh sports turf
soils and and some options there so
thanks everybody for joining we'll we'll
see you next week see you guys see you
mike thanks a lot brother this has been
a production of cornell university on
the web at cornell.edu